[Musique]
je
on
[Musique]
mon sens
vous
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
grâce à toi mon cher aux femmes voilà
l'endroit le plus haut et le plus secret
de la tour neuve comme de vrais
prisonniers d'êta et ce n'est pas facile
d'entrer ici et encore moins d'en sortir
si on n'est pas l'avis de jose la cev le
guichetier de cet estimable chambre de
la mort c'est que pas des régions on
appelait la tour du berceau à très très
peur
nous évitons qui s'est passé ici de ce
terrible chose qu est à tel point que
j'ai peur à présent tu voulais raconter
par guerre est là c'est que nous vivons
en ce moment et c'est ici que le faire
de notre reine marie tudor aurait vite
énorme gonflé dos rond j'ai dû lutter
plus assoiffés de sang que jamais un
onduleur
un douzaine jeanne il regardait par
cette croisée brûler les prisonniers à
56 au dessous de lui dans la cour des
prisons pendant ce temps là câble
jusqu'au dernier souffle continuer dé
dicter des ordres de bord mieux et
hurlements des victimes est depuis aux
rien n'a bougé
la tour du berceau est devenu un musée
funèbre que visite quelques privilégiés
sa fille marie il vient souvent les
veilles d'exécution comme si elle
puisait ici son intro ce courage pour
continuer les folie sanguinaire de son
père en permanence depuis la mort
d'henri viii et bien souvent pour aller
plus vite les tourmenteurs jurés
flagelle à mort d'obscurs tant d'années
avant les faire disparaître dans les
gouffres de la tête par une dalle de
leur cachot s'ouvrant brusquement leur
pied
d'ailleurs trois condamnations sont
prévus pour la tombée du jour
un son de cloche ne vous abandonnerai
une demi-heure et je vous accompagnerai
ma petite jeanne cas les bords de la
tamise où vous demeurez sont dangereuses
depuis qu'elles sont c'est condamner le
sait qu'au dernier moment sur un ordre
signé de la reine tout de suite après la
cloche coup de canon quand j'ouvre les
cachots un second quand les malheureux
arrive au pied de l'échafaud et un
troisième colabor a fait son oeuvre
c'est fait on ne tremblait pas au maquis
john
quelle idée aussi d'avoir insisté pour
monter jusqu ici cette visite ne peut
que fortifier notre haine pour l'affreux
régime des tudors mois ils sont
l'injustice la dictature l'oppression
avant que je vous raconte
parlons un peu de vous et à votre
mariage vous envoie allumèrent attendent
à neuf dans une semaine
n'est ce pas jeunes il est impossible d
une fiancée plus joli et d'un fiancé
plus amoureux à quelle chance vous avez
mes enfants d'être heureux dans un
régime aussi cruel et toi je sois tu
n'es pas heureux on tu sais qu il ya
longtemps j'ai annoncé à tous et depuis
tant d'années que j'en attends à ce sont
ces que je sais que les portes qu'elle
ouvre ne se refermeront jamais sur ceux
qui en sortent et je n'ai pas l'âme
entretenir dépenses et joyeuse à temps
j'avais votre âge
maty diane là j'étais comme un autre
amoureux tout un jour ambitieux tout un
vrai fou toute la vie parle-nous d'henri
vite
c'est effrayant pouvant table sans si je
l'avais pas vu de mes yeux entendu de
mes oreilles lorsque je ne porte clés
jeter le registre des condamnations le
corridor derrière cette tapisserie
croyez que la vrille mais gare peu
d'historiens en savent autant que moi
par mon bon jour soit environ 12 ans au
mois d'octobre
à la tombée du jour leroy rue89 l'infâme
le plus envie de le débaucher les
animistes et de la boue vivante mais qui
vous plaît à toi / j'aime pas les jaunes
d'oeufs de lait duc de northumberland si
c'est vrai jour i et ii le décès du king
air exquis jour où je vous excuse
arthur ans guy béart tirage de galles
ensuite on voit la baignoire henry
éleveurs je m'excuse en riffs on les
touche finale de votre portrait ou
bouger beaucoup si je te paie assez cher
pour avoir le droit de bouger votre
montre au mali gens
vraiment tu a ajouté un titre atone en
nombre restait holbein me suis fait
merci c'est demandé il date de leur
mariage
j'oublie je fais tous mes fans je
connais ma vie mieux 3 le peuple aussi
les connais henry dieu sait pourquoi il
gronde populaire mais moi je suis en 3e
et âme à ton nom moi ton chat prière à
la mémoire de serge leurs rayons en 1533
vous avez obligé l'archevêque de
canterbury appel de son véritable nom
kramer gilles carle nommé archevêque
même vous qu'il avait obligé le
prononcer le divorce avec votre première
femme malgré la communication de paul
iii
catherine d'aragon c'était une piste je
le saurai du lycée de voir ce qu'elle
m'a donné matri glaris marie héritière
des tudors marie tudor
abondant à 12 ans aux poils à la résille
et et elle me ressemble à petit car les
dames succès
si vous n'aviez pas fait en 1535
décapité votre deuxième femme à molène
vous sent le raffinement jusqu'à offrir
se déchire en spectacle à jane ces mots
votre troisième mandat et puis un bolet
me trompais c'est faux la corde mais
joli chèque après tandis que nous
cessons de vous acharner sur catherine
d'aragon la mère de votre fille l'a
relégué à vis dans le sombre château de
kim bolton risque à tour et poison six
mois après en 1536 vous avez fait ouvrir
le ventre
votre troisième femme non plus pourquoi
la croyance atteint sur la folie
difficulté l'héritage avec marie quant à
votre quatrième femme anne de clèves en
1540 que je mens les flandres nature
dans le bail m'avait trompé
teulade les bannis maintenant on vous
l'avait enfermée dans une forteresse en
vous vengeant sur votre meilleur ami dr
thomas cromwell que vous avez fait
décapiter en 1541 uniquement parce qu'il
vous avait conseillé ce mariage
il me fallait un responsable six mois
après le 12 février 1541 vous avez fait
couper la tête de votre cinquième femme
catherine howard sans lui permettre de
prendre un défenseur il prend qu'une
coupe qui me fait mal chaque fois que
dudley à l'offre d'essai les gages d'une
de mes favoris car après
on a vu des âmes en avant notre mariage
ça ne pardonne pas aurait pardonné toi
quant à votre sixième femme catherine
parr vous l'avait condamné au bûcher en
1543 je veux tu avais demandé de
seulement rappelé les mariages et décès
sont des histoires privées ça ne regarde
pas la populace du journaliste nous on
n'en finirait pas duc de buckingham
cardinal fischer le chancelier thomas
cement détail des chiffres total 123
alors magistrat docteur militaire
décapité 1052 moines évêques prêtres aux
fonctionnaires contrôleur des impôts
artistes et artisans brûler quand on va
peut être le paysan vous riez on la
tourne les freins
combien on les enregistre les prisons
porte à ce jour 2113 pendu allemand où
je passe sous silence les milliers
d'autres torturés massacrés dans leur
demeure par vaux lansquenets pour votre
bon plaisir non landry je peux blais en
exterminant les vieillards les navires
les enfants trop grand nombre
d'enseignés les purs leurs assauts est
ce que tout cela a bougé la guerre ou la
presse qu'une bhutto
nous vient du registre de joie le jeune
biche qui ira on peut qu'ils l'aient que
crois-tu gagner avec le bilan post
d'historiens de votre majesté est bien
trop petit pour ça il faudrait voir en
vrai quoi comprendre enfin jean
comprendre et saint jean saint jean
l'apocalypse je ferai un vrai bloc mon
frère royaume bron lui tellement bien
jeux et du roi en en place j'aurais fait
pire
on rit il ne manque pas d'audace
même les mélomanes je te pète mais pas
pour te payer ma tête à tout pour
aujourd'hui holbein parfait
pourquoi les pieds de prise le 5 et le
plein c'est la première fois à sir le
sens et qu réguler le froid sans doute
pardonnez moi
et puis lui christophe c jusqu'à la fin
du monde sap en duos fait pour cette
négligence mais pas le compte de barbe
bleue que je vous fais la marque john
mais l'histoire du tyran le plus
impitoyable que l'angleterre ait connu
est impossible de s'expliquer la cruauté
mystique de marie tudor aujourd'hui si
on ne connaît pas les détails de cette
nuit historique où fut consommé le
divorce entre la grande communauté
catholique et l'église anglicane loin du
sens et demi le battre sur deux fronts
contre des papistes contre les
protestants allemands sont dans les
protestants je veux savoir ce que cet
ignoble imron de lutter écrit sur moi et
donc ça va voir comment ce travail ne
m'avez vous pas nommé duc de norfolk aux
siens en fanfare au sima qui te plaît
luke donald en contre mais je vais tout
vous n'aurez pas l'accord de mon vendre
alors j'attends du norfolk limmois soli
bellon duriez d'une terre qui se promène
dans tintin
je ne sais si la folie elle même est
aussi insensé qui la tête du pauvre
maniaque sanguinaire henri viii au que
je voudrais bien couvrir sept musiciens
anglaise debout et d'ordures
j'en ai bien le droit et j'ai pu me
procurer l'original écrit et signé de sa
main
martin luter pourtant 1000 marques
devant toulouse aura préparé norfolk le
bill 200 pour le parlement
décrétons l'arrestation et l'exécution
capitale sans jugement le tout les
protestants l'abjuration ne modifie en
rien le cours de notre justice
il me faut le champ libre à 6
la mort pour tous ses effectifs de
l'intérieur c'est le plus grand acte de
votre règne la confiscation voulons bien
élastique au profit de la couronne bull
1 6 1 quel supplice le feu nous avons
cependant comme j'aime cette musique
visible que sont pour moi les flammes du
bûcher mais crépitement du feu
ils sont très puissants sur le
catholique ne sont rien pour la protéger
car je vais l'oreille fine mois alors le
décider on ne brûlera plus les
protestants on les pendra ne vois pas
mon indice crèche à plein nez sans doute
à nous écouter derrière la tenture comme
d'habitude de tighmert ne m'appelez plus
g
vous m'avez nommé vous-même archevêque
de 14
brault simon louvoyante ami tu tiens à
ton titre premier rares serait de
l'église anglicane aux prises le signer
se bile de sang contre tous les
luthériens du royaume
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce que ce n'est oublié tous
comme des chèvres
merci archevêque mais f dont que ce
ruban papale si les deux plans qui sent
pas le droit plane équipant votre des
frac
je devine et où sir c'est en effet la
bulle d'excommunication majeur de paul
iii contre vous régis mini militants
petit sac les y est voilà pourquoi je
n'osais pas entrer mois kamini le pape
refuse de vous reconnaître chef de
l'église d'angleterre
il vous déclare déchets 1
imperium reggie à brogard et oui déchu
de la couronne pour avoir fomenté le
schisme entre les églises à votre profit
et placez votre puissance temporelle au
dessus de sa puissance spirituelle
il interdit aux catholiques anglais de
payer 10 mai un pot à votre couronne une
perpetuum qu'on sait quoi taux des
actifs smith paul iii ajouté verbalement
je tiens ce mou de son secrétaire d'état
c'est henri viii est à prendre comme un
goret mais il a osé dire barrère
charlatans de dieu
par ce pape diabolique astrologue qui
demandent leur grille eusement aux
astres ce qu'il devrait te demander
humblement à toi il ose interrogé mars
et vénus à ta place
fini le pacte enfin libres libres avec
toi mon dieu avec toi mon christ plus
personne d'entre nous moi l'homme étant
le parlement chef et protecteur de
l'église d'angleterre toi rois du ciel
et la mort par le feu
pour tous ceux qui essaieront de nous
empêcher de nous rejoindre
moi et toi
quand ans l'archevêque de cantorbéry que
je suis excommunié en même temps que
vous inspire une chaîne a dominé les
foudres du vatican gel en passant les
alpes
nous allons les faire fondre dans les
flammes de nos bus chez vous me frayer
dans les cordes du diable si c'est un
pis le pôle trois essais tous les
papistes influent mais oeuvre inspirée
par dieu
l'institution du chrétien dans huit mois
d'après mission s'est laissée là tout
chrétien dans la vie également serait
épargné les flammes purificatrice dans
lesquels je vais être obligé de les
jeter
écoutez ci-haut excusez-moi si une
rébellion armée des catholiques pour
éviter le bûcher qu'ils prennent les
devants
on était près de l'efs vous préparer un
nouveau deal de ça pour la sambre et la
dénonçant tous les papistes nous accuse
de ponte trahison elle conspiration
contre le régime
stupide ou le refus infaillibilité
retenu par la chambre des lords dont
l'acte de suprématie qui me fait ch
unique l'église d'angleterre je te
ferait plus de mal à moi tout seul
aucun roi le prétend faire et des forces
de son royaume
les évêques sont des loups dévorant les
moines des sépulcres blanchis au feu au
feu des papilles sur la basse terre leur
abbaye nos accessoires de théâtre mais
s'ils consentent adjuré dont on accepte
l'organisation est une condition qu'il
soit en ciel à travers moi les autres
catholiques découpé en morceaux
épaulé par ce n'est que l'église
anglicane signer l'arrêt de mort de tous
les papilles
[Musique]
petit grain ne meurt il ne s'agit pas de
lieu mais de politique
kantari daf leurs 200 la signature
pèsera lourdement sur l'histoire de
l'église d'angleterre
signé après l'archevêque pour la chambre
des lords conseil et 3 réunit de donald
tusk de northumberland
pato ratifié cette nuit par le parlement
quand albeau qui à rome vous a trahis
cyr le hasard est il a dit au faz que
vous étiez le nerrant de l'angleterre
et dès son retour il a préparé la
réunion
la police a saisi leurs talons l'année
dernière les armes à la main il est en
prison j'ai refusé sa grâce son duché
près donc elle pleurait sans que ça on
en fait
le livre ici son poulet la tamise non
mira demain ces verbes cadavre de piste
savez vous que la femme de talbot encore
plus papiste que talbot palliera pas
pensé j'y pense et si rassurer la coupe
une cellule voisine de celle de son
vieux mari elle est enceinte mais très
moisis 500h d'attention si eddie talbot
un héritier adieu la fabuleuse fortune
pour la couronne
le cas de l'irlande waterford 200 mille
ha oui baronnies 74 paroisse la loi vous
donne droit de confiscation sur tout ce
que vous faites est exécuté mais pas sur
leurs héritiers directs et pour
l'instant il n'y en a pas c'est à dire
pas encore
ils hall dit talbot disparaissent sans
laisser de postérité détruire dans le
trail et mes deux tomes des tarifs
relève je te fais prince waterford
parfois rêveur physique et moi ainsi
rekem graverie 14 à la cloche m'appeler
majesté
[Applaudissements]
tout de suite
immédiatement avec le dit talbot est sur
le point d'accoucher
justement à cause de cela et si mal en
point
vraiment un transportable je pense que
20 pour le point cela je veux la voir
riez avec son mari et jeter dans le feu
avec lui à la même seconde
à moins que tu ne devrais je précédé
d'exécuter vos ordres
comme me sens un peu plus de 2 jugé
cette triplette à l'eau dès demain il
prépare et porté à 2 dans toute
l'angleterre d'innombrables bus et qui
resteront elle n'est joué ni par
extraction je gagnais pas triste
le seul
seul purificateur pour leur argent perry
n'est ce pas
de là j'ai tout entendu c'est horrible
oui mais quelle répercussion dans
l'univers car c'est de cette nuit là
qu'est née l'église anglicane pauvre lui
dit talbot fut brûlé loup si belle et le
savoir norfolk retenir ma fille marie
qui tiendrait le chevalet liste
d'exécution il faut qu'elles
sensibilisent à ses spectacles
elle aura besoin de ma force d'âme quand
elle me succédera faire ta fortune dans
un instant qui va mourir lors talbot et
sa femme papistes et rébellion a marre
mais c'est le moins que je puisse faire
les des talbot aussi quand j'étais petit
l'étal bonne note il pas défendu ma mère
catherine d'aragon contre toi justement
à cause de cela marie papistes comme
catherine ils doivent mourir c'est
uniquement à cause de toi que j'épargne
est amer qui les a dénoncés moi et moi
mais c'est quand même il faut qu'elle
s'aguerrissent échec au roi
non
[Musique]
m
faire voilà les détails qu il se laisse
traîner et elle déjà morte
leur talbot s'agenouille il tend les
bras vers toi père père qui sont bien
maladroits les bourreaux pour les
attacher ensemble
voir les
voilà
3 hors du monde tu hérites en ce moment
les gardes l'irlande de l'admirable
ville mois terre en forme de cent mille
hectares 74 marois 8 baronnies j'enquête
ans elle est pour toi un diamant chaque
volutes de fumée d'abord de l'or et
châteaux des flancs des montagnes qui
serait au ciel qui sera l'arène la plus
riche de la terre c'est gratuitement
voir
quelques vols tu les entendre oui si
paul
attendez leçon impitoyable de cet ordre
qui ont fait de cette jeune fille la
terrifiante marie tudor d'aujourd'hui
moi qui vous parle j'ai senti leur aussi
bien souvent et je suis pas sûr de ne
pas avoir été deux ou trois fois
dépendez à c'était un temps à singulier
peu près semblable à celui que nous
vivons car pour ce qui est des jb dh et
des bûchers reine marie ne laisse pas
chômé et son père henri 8 malgré sa
cruauté me semble parfois côté d'elle un
enfant de choeur et non seulement il ya
toujours sur la tourelle d'entrée du
pont de londres a pour autant de
nouvelles têtes coupées qu'il ya 19 ans
mais dans la seule nuit de jeudi dans la
forêt d'amos et y ait plus de branches
assez solide plus assez d'eau corps de
plus à ses deux bourreaux pour les 300
protestants il m'a fallu prendre de ses
grandes joies meresse la même que la
tienne vial et mais gilbert de tout
notre coeur chacun à notre façon
archi archi j'en parlerai chacun de
doute doit la vie et tous les deux le
pas seule porte de rêve
jeanne n'était qu'une pauvre orpheline
abandonnés dans la rue et à la fin de la
nuit de sa naissance elle a trouvé un
rayon de soleil toi gilbert qui l'a
recueilli et élevé mois par un soir de
gros temps et failli me noyer dans la
tamise en faisant fuir un prisonnier
tu m'a tiré de l'eau la jeanne est
important le bonheur acquittera ma dette
n'ont même pas la sienne
alors bon j'arrive au contrôle des
exécutions que nous annonçait par tous
il ben non non il est trop tard vous
vous attendiez que je remonte en rester
là tranquille oubliée la tour de londres
et ses cauchemars
mais puisque la pudeur de jeanne
s'offusque de te recevoir chez elle
depuis vous est fiancée et que je ne
veux plus pour le même motif allaitantes
en atelier et mais profiter de ce lieu
pour vous parler d'amour autrement que
dans les brouillards et berges de la
tamise
je ne défends pas d'en faire autant
josuha raisons j'avais hâte être avec
toi jane m'aimes tu mais je vous dois
toucher
je ne sais quoi mener quel chez trop
longtemps qu'est-ce que je serai bon du
tout ce que je suis vous l'avez fait
tout ce que j'ai donné charme même tu
vous travaillé jour et nuit pour moi
vous vous tuer
c'est là qu'on passait tout cas niveau 6
les quelques manches de poignard je ne
sais quelle riche partie ce qui pourrait
les échéances de la petite maison que je
t'ai louer et vêtements que je sais vous
avez quelquefois manqué de page je n'ai
jamais manqué de rumeurs
cela ne dis pas que tu m'aimes c'est de
ce mot seul que j'ai besoin jeanne
jamais me tue
gilbert je voudrais vous prouver ma
reconnaissance lorsque les changements
mais je ne veux pas de reconnaissance
je veux ton amour ou rien depuis 18 ans
que je t'ai traitait comme ma fille y en
a trop pris l'habitude mais tu vas être
ma femme
comprend le tulle a promis
tu mets mais quand tu m'as promis
[Musique]
depuis trois semaines il me semble que
quelque chose ait changé doit signer
d'habitude je te vois triste et le soir
toujours préoccupé
natural je suis un honnête artisan je
préférerais être un chenapan il ya très
peu de toi si tu savais comme je t'aime
je crie c'est gilbert
book tu pleures
ces deux joueurs n'est ce pas
on dit moins que c'est de joie j'ai
besoin de croire que vous avez j
je suis jaloux ces derniers temps j'ai
cru voir quelques jeunes singer du
voyage à ce prêtre s'arrêter et rôder
autour de ta maison
j'ai peur que tu me compare l j'ai 38
ans je suis un misérable le voyais mal
vêtues ni jeune ni beau et j'adore une
fille de 18 ans que nous suivent noble
et riche comme ces petits seigneurs par
pitié jeunes ne les regarde pas je
regarde tout le monde mais je ne vois
que vous partager l'amour injuste dit ce
que tu as les dirigeants
c'est une exécution le theux bouleverse
pas d'ailleurs nous ne pouvons rien voir
jose va nous dire ah tout à leurs débuts
j'entends les crépitements
croit-elle
trois coups de hache gilbert vous avez
entendu une femme crier
ok
je vais monter à bord y est horrible
d'athlétisme à berlin
celui là il le mérite mais jane grey il
son mari tu essaies signé maïga
catholique et fabien n'écoule taclant
brasil
c'est le plus grand crime de l'époque je
suis entré dans son cachot
la reine lui ayant refusé sa grâce j'ai
levé la tête vers cette chambre où il
avait signé 18 ans plus tôt sous la
contrainte mobile contre les protestants
et retrouver le compte n'y est pas
puisque bouleversant un tournoi des
choses
elle a dû revivre en un éclair cette
scène avec henri 8 que je venais
justement de vous raconter les bons en
martyrs comme un illuminé qui a retrouvé
la première sinon jusqu'à la fin de
prêcher dans les flammes ces doctrines
luthérienne quand on se trompe et mes
amis quand vous affirmant que par son
green c'est implacable rennes vient de
faire ce soir de l'archevêque de
canterbury
le patriarche de l'église anglicane ce
fabien ni de compte des plans brasse il
qu'ils attachent à ces crimes sa
signature
je me souviens de son nom tout connu non
mais il m'a envoyé 100 vallées ir pour
ciseler ses armoiries sur un première en
or qui est ce un jeune homme de 20 ans
premièrement parce qu'on dit il la porte
et l'espagne est monstrueux décret de
l'acquisition est temps que ceux ci
resteront à sa lecture favorite la
tamise continuera à rouler du sang son
premier amant à 36 ans premiers amours
sensuelles puis une mystique exalté 36
ans qui a hérité la côté de son père
multiplie les dangers que son caprice
fait courir en angleterre ça paiera
loose il est pourquoi parce qu'elle
n'écoute que ce charmant jeune homme du
fait signer chaque nuit entre 2 et 30 la
mort de tous ceux qui pourraient lui
barrer la route pour s'approprier leurs
titres leurs privilèges
tandis que son côté la joute à la liste
funèbres les noms les plus vénérés des
pasteurs protestants
je vous en prie partance usa beau vous
raccompagne roja jose miguel avec son
travail de nuit il n'a plus le temps
si je veux se reproduire je ne jamais
perdre une minute la présence
[Musique]
c'est un endroit rêvé pour une
conspiration mais plus encore pour les
pitchouns voulez-vous dire leur montaigu
les amis le temps de presse les trois
coups de canon que nous voulons entendre
un prêche pour nous l'heure de la
décision la semaine prochaine ce sera
notre tour du nord il a fallu l'arrivée
dans le lit de la reine de fabiani
troisième manière qu pour faire de notre
chambre dès lors un cimetière
et dire que cette aventure dit l'italien
au sortir de la grande famille espagnole
d'epinal var mais la reine ne peut plus
passer lui ne vit que par lui ni coups
que lui
si elle est une nuit sans lui ses yeux
deviennent languissant comme au temps où
elle aimait le cardinal paul hus n'est
ce pas m simon renard menthe amoureux
elle fait lors d'angleterre comme nous
l'a l'ordre de la jarretière comme nous
à quel titre
et depuis qu'elle l'a nommé conseiller
aux deux oeuvres les bûchers sont
toujours braise et lâche du bourg où
c'était vrai chez tous les soirs si cela
vous est facile à dire avoue m simonard
cet ambassadeur d'espagne chef des
services secrets de charles quint
représenté ici son fils philippe deux
futurs maris grain votre personne ce
titre et sacré pour le favori mais nous
pour lui nos têtes nous sont que des
bilboquets le tome ne me gêne pas moins
que vous vous craignez pour vos vies moi
je craque mon crédit charles quint est
intraitable
je paierai de ma vie mon incapacité si
je n'arrivais pas à marier son fils à
marie du nord comment vous c'était le
temps de presse sont décapite demain tir
conel si je rencontre cette nuit donc je
cherche qui reconnaît le supra avec vous
demain soir
voulez vous dire qu'adviendra-t-il de
fabiani vous avez de bons yeux mais l'or
il ya en ce moment un homme est encore
là à westminster et qui demain d'arrêt
hier le raïs à la tour de l'eau que dieu
vous soit en aide
le diable il suffira le peuple ne l'est
pas moins que nous qu'elle fait dans
l'ordre le jour de sa chute qui pourrait
aussi entraîner sa fiche
vous êtes de loyaux sujets milord rien
contre la reine tout contre fabiani nous
sommes mises entre vos mains monsieur le
bayer que faut-il faire
rien les images eersel cet endroit n'est
pas bon pour vous rentrez dans vos
demeures
je voudrais tout ce qu'il faut à votre
place vous avez confiance en moi il vous
suffira donc demain matin petit levée de
la reine si elle vous interroge de lui
juré avoir vu et entendu ce que je
voudrais raconter quelques instants
auparavant
nous le jugerons certainement monsieur
le vayer d'autant que notre conspiration
n'est pas dirigé contre elle sinon elle
nous prendrait tout ce qu'on possède
louvre on rêve tout au plus que voter
monsieur le pays
pour mort en sursis de la tyrannie
d'études à
une heure de sommeil bonne nuit mon cher
sinon un instant encore jamais regarde
là bien je vous la laisse pas qu'elle
est belle et qu'elle ferait l'orgueil
marois je me fais une joie d'être à
votre annonce dans huit jours
j'espère que les affaires d'états menés
sont enfin apple liberté quelle affaire
d'état j'ai entendu dire que dans les 24
heures
fabiani serait peut-être plus petits
c'est pas un prix qui eut quelques coups
fait cette nuit j'ai perçu tout à
l'heure l'ombre de simon renards contre
le temps avec des ombres de l'or ainsi
mois on a été dense et puissant ce
ciment au nord est ne m et le cra n ont
rien contre lui il a déjà fait
disparaître deux ou trois favoris ils
nettoient le palais de temps en temps la
norme subtil c'est tout ce qui s'y passe
et il creuse toujours deux ou trois
étages d'un trick souterraine sous tous
les événements à ce jose la commune nous
débite couramment toutes ces histoires
mais si gilbert l'homme qui connaît le
mieux l'histoire de ce temps ci c'est le
guichetier la tour de londres
et moi je suis preneur
il aimerait y partir de celui ces sortes
de gens qui rôdent autour de ta maison
de déplaire demain ce qu'il peut faire
par ici
menton tout de suite j'ai l'impression
qu'il me prépare de la besogne
adieu val-jalbert soyez heureux mais
encore
soit bientôt minuit je suis fatigué de
ma gibert à mon dieu
que j'ai de la peine à m'arracher de toi
et puis après tout même mois où on n'a
même pas ça tu regardes mais si tu ne
m'aimes pas
j'aimerais mieux mourir je m'en vais
dessus fou pardonne moi va-t-on travail
j'espère
cet accueil que tu cherches non oui je
pensais pas qu'ils viendraient jusqu'ici
que dis tu je suis si discrète
j'ai dû la perdre sauf qu est ce que tu
aurais fait tout seul la porte fermée
c'est de la chance que j'en ai le double
il renferme toi bien
demain matin je t'ai fait dans huit
jours a toujours je t'aime je t'aime
[Musique]
on
pour soir me permettez-vous d'entrée
avec vous dans votre chope on va
connaissez tous sont pas si je te
reconnais tu le mendiant juifs qui
rôdait depuis quelques jours à l'entrée
du pont de londres autour de mon échoppe
non vous ne me reconnaissez pas ça ne
fait rien gilbert tu connais mon nom
c'était un comble oui c'est un comble et
ça le sera davantage dans un instant au
diable si je te comprends parle je suis
pressé c'est genre ouais waris
gentilhomme qui s'appelle le compte de
l'embrasser vous le connaissez non
seulement son ballet qui donnait au
matin chercher mon travail entrée
excusez moi monsieur je viens chercher
le poignard de l'orc lembras il
il est pas tout à fait terminé ça ne
fait rien l'orque lembras il sort cette
nuit dans un lieu désert il préfère
avoir cette arme sur lui vous leur
apporterez demain je ne pense pas qu'il
reviendra
pourquoi nutrition mais j'ai quelque
chose à vous apprendre il ya 18 ans dans
la même nuit ou l'orge talbot et sa
femme furent brûlés ses partisans pas
pistes étaient taillés en pièces par les
soldats du roi henri on sort que musa
dans la nuit cette nuit là un jeune
ouvrier beaucoup plus occupé de sa
besogne que de la guerre henry 8 et les
papistes de leurs talbot
travailler ici même dans cette échoppe
alors que les balles traversait la
tamise dans ses flancs
[Musique]
j'ai trouvé cet enfant il ya quelques
instants derrière un portail
il bougeait tout à l'heure je ne sais
s'il y va de toute façon je ne puis
moins chargé je me bats avec les
catholiques contre le tyran et si on
veut trouver on te tuerais avec moi
ça fait sept enfants monsieur
permettez-moi de fuir ben vous êtes bons
jeunes hommes n'ont pas aussi bon dans
ces personnes est entré chez vous j'ai
fait non personne
merci bonne chance
sourit jeanne les petites filles
vous voyez accepta l'enfant l'adopta
l'orpheline il éleva il les mains il fit
de cette enfant l'objet unique de son
travail de ces affections de sa vie ils
veulent à 18 ans que cela dure
vous voyez c'était vous
tout est vrai dans ce que vous dites
le blessé c'était moi
maintenant je vous reconnais
je ne remercierai jamais assez de la
petite lumière qui embellit ma vie non
je ne le mérite pas je me suis
débarrassé d'un paquet voilà tout
j'avais trouvé sous la tête l'enfant le
chiffon
je garde toujours sur moi il avait écrit
avec du sang sauver jeanne je l'avais
vue n'avait jamais su d'où venait cet
enfant
non mais puisque vous voulez me
remercier êtes vous prêt à mourir si
c'est en mon pouvoir oui c'est facile
venez immédiatement avec moi venir à
cette heure nous vous le verrez vous
pourrez vous dispenser de terminer votre
poignard le compte de clans brasse il
n'en aura plus besoin
que voulez-vous dire venez je vous en
prie venez
pourquoi ma main puis ici c'est la
maison de gens très bien que je suis au
pouvoir dans toute pratique et
heureusement
est ce que tu veux dire vous le
comprendrez tout à l'heure
ne retournez pas votre chope gilbert
c'est un avis que je vous donne pour ne
pas vous nuire à vous même que de
mystère dans vos paroles jeu plus à vous
c'est moi intervenu en commun sauf si
vous m'entendez appelé m'avoir gardé ses
papiers pendant quelques instants
j'en retiendrai voulait entendre tout à
l'heure sont à moi mais si par hasard il
m'a fait mal à les sauver ta voix toute
propriété
je serais trop loin pour vous voir et
vous entendre avec ce brouillard c'est
bien ainsi au pays c'est moi il
n'intervenait que si vous entendez
collier
quand je ne
l'attention parce qu'ils soient dans le
brouillard milan c'est un choc qu'on
connaît larry d'acier sur ma guitare
[Rires]
dans sa barque jeu reviendra au chant du
coq à vos ordres monseigneur anneaux
s'il vous plaît qui es-tu marron ce qui
vous plaira que je sois mon père n'est
clair mal mais tu as un bonnet jaune les
amandiers en juif
oui je le suis j'ai quelque chose à vous
dire comment t'appelles-tu je sais votre
nom vous ne savez pas le mien je ne
vends pas sur vous permettez moi de le
garder tu sais mon nom tout cela n'est
pas vrai annappes vous appelez signant
fabiani à madrid dont fabiano à londres
vous êtes devenu l'ordre abiali mais à
paris on vous appellera fabiani que le
diable ton porte
nous serions bien brouillonne je te
ferai pas étonné je n'aime pas qu'on
sache mon nom quand la nuit je paye
surtout quand vous allez là où vous
allez je veux tu dire si la reine le
savez je ne vais nulle part si milla
vous allez chez la belle jane la fiancée
de gilbert le ciseleur nous est fou mon
pauvre juifs
mais voir attendre davantage vous avez
séduit cette jeune fille est depuis un
mois elle vous a reçu cinq fois chez
elle
la nuit c'est aujourd'hui la sixième la
belle vous attends tu toi tu veux de
l'argent proto terre combien je veux
bien plus que de l'argent mais nous
verrons cela tout à l'heure en attendant
voulez vous que je vous dise pourquoi
vous avez séduit c'est fini par bleu
parce que j'en étais amoureux non je
n'en étais pas amoureux pas plus que de
la reine d'ailleurs tu es toi je n'étais
pas amoureux de jane non calcul oui
désir c'est selon les uns la reine 38
ans jeanne 19 ça drôle tu n'es pas un
homme tué ma conscience des dix ans je
vais donc vous parler comme elle le
ferait si vous l'interrogiez avec
sincérité mais nous sommes trop près de
cette maison vous devez être seul tendre
c'est très important ce que je vais vous
dire vous perdez dix minutes d'amour
macy gray de votre vie
celui qui mettrai ma vie en danger ne
verrait pas le jour suivant ou
changerait d'avis milla éloignant nous
mettons nous à la baille là bas
vous êtes le favori de la reine et si
elle vous a comblé de titre ronflant de
ses beau collier que les sultanats
taches de couleurs esclaves
elle ne vous a jamais donné de l'argent
l'état va vous le savez alors que vous
cherchiez de bonnes terres de bons
bailliage et de bons revenus à bonn
livres sterling au nom des huit avez
vous le saviez confisquer les biens de
leurs talbot profit de la couronne et
jamais la reine n'avait voulait toucher
à cette immense fortune catholique
par respect pour la mémoire des talbot
mort pour la défendre
il était là à votre portée vous avez
saisi l'occasion elle vous les a donnés
mais pour que cette donation fut valable
il fallait que leurs paquebots fumeurs
sans postérité
s'il existait un héritier ou une eric r
comme leur talbot était pas piste comme
catherine d'aragon et comme mclaren
il n'est pas douteux que marie tudor
vous reprendrez bien tout favori que
vous êtes et les rendre et par devoir et
par religion
eric et ou à l'héritière vous étiez
assez tranquille de ce côté mais la
providence en ma personne à les déjouer
vos plans
j'ai participé moi même à la rébellion
comprend rien au heat la rameuse nuitées
l'exécution des talbot et que celui-ci
et sa femme fume quelques puis 2-1 à
porto bourreau de la tour de l'an non
laissez moi je suis blessé amour écoutez
moi il ya une heure alors que leur
talbot était déjà lié sur le bûcher un
ordre est venu à dermique de brûler sa
femme en même temps évanoui une
baignaient dans le sang telle bouleversé
[Musique]
10h24 sur son passage pour il est dit
allez les pétoires
airelle exclu fort a quitté feu sur le
grill avec ses parents c'est l'ordre du
roi
y à t'il
et r
trois ceintures la petite clé dans la
porte secrète des passages souterrains
un bordelais
hermel aussi tu peux en donner demain
sans du grand amour revient au courant
que jamais personne ne le sache ce
serait la mort pour nous
j'ai prises avec moi peut-être vital
encore porté là avec vous et sauver la
le feu gagne et 3 au mois
[Musique]
vous est ce qu on avait découvert que
dans la nuit lors talbot et sont parties
furent exterminés ou petite fille avait
été mystérieusement déposé chez un
ouvrier qu'il était probable que cet
enfant élevé sous le nom de jeunes et
john talbot l'incident était fâché se
voit peut-être forcée de rendre un jour
à une petite fiche roseberry wexford est
une belle ville le magnifique conte et
de waterford et une immense fortune
c'est dur un autre que vous aurez
chercher faire disparaître la jeune
fille miller vous avez fait mieux vous
avez déshonoré
attention aux paroles n'est pas que
c'est votre conscience qui vous parle
cela ne regarde que moi
la même marié plus quoiqu'il étonnamment
elle est très menacé elle peut être
assassiné d'une heure à l'autre les
preuves matérielles de l'état de la
jeune fille peuvent sans la trouver
et alors si la reine nour et jeanne tout
déshonoré que vous l'avez fait sera
reconnu comme mary kerr les talbot et
vous tomberiez pauvre comme job sur le
tombeau de la reine eh bien eh bien
[Musique]
vous avez conduit la chose avec adresse
vous avez caché votre nom vous êtes à
couvert du côté de la reine
la pauvre jeune croate avoir été séduite
par un chevalier nommé à mias pas où il
est
c'est donc le dial allons maintenant au
fait que me veux-tu
mais là si quelqu'un avait en son
pouvoir des papiers qui constate la
naissance l'existence et les droits de
l'erika talbot cela ne vous laisserai
plus d'autres châteaux dans fabiano que
vos châteaux en espagne au fait merci
les papiers prouvant l'existence de
l'héritière qui les possède moi pauvre
look misérable du mans où les a tués ici
même je ne te crois pas bien en règle
une preuve formelle
ce que tu peux raconter là n'est pas
signée jonathan zebina une façon si
logique de raconter des gasconnades
comme disent les français qu'un autre
que moi s'y laisse répondre mais
j'attends toujours la preuve
indiscutable que l'enfant de la dit
talbot était bien dans la prison mais
l'aide gourou qui est mort près de moi
me l'a dit en ne confiant l'enfant dois
je te dire que le témoignage d'un mort
par la bouche d'un juif
en angleterre c'est risible comme tu
crains la corde elle te sers ray le coup
avant la fin de ton parjure et bien sûr
fabiani je vais vous la donne et c'est
pavie réfutable y en a c'est qu'il s'en
remette
tu mens déguerpis aussi non
il n'ya qu'un homme dont le témoignage
de l'existence de l'héritière pourrait
être indiscutable c'est celui du
bourreau oui j'ai ce témoignage celui de
dermik le bourreau denrées 8 mai il est
mort depuis longtemps tout londres le
sect non il n'est pas moi apprenant le
motif de ma visite pour l'andra jeanne
talbot son rang et sa fortune dermik me
remit sa confession confirmant l'aveu de
son jeune et de bourreau et authentifié
par les bénédictins auquel il avait fait
des remix appris aussi que leur talbot
prévoyant après l'échec de sa rébellion
que lui et sa femme enceinte serait
exécutée avait fait parvenir à catherine
d'aragon son testament léguant sa
fortune et ses titres à l'enfant attendu
vu celui-ci mettre en prison
catherine d'aragon avant de mourir avait
pu confier ce qu'est ce t'as mans en
monastère pour le soustraire aux
persécuteurs dermique me l'a remis je
l'est avec le testament et toutes les
annexes
si tu as vraiment ces documents combien
ça n'a pas de prix
juif donne moi ces papiers juifs
misérablement d'iran qui passe dans les
rues donne moi la ville de shrewsbury
town mois la ville d'oxford
donne moi le quart de l'irlande la
charité s'il vous plaît papiers sont
tout pour moi ne font rien pour toi
6 - renard et leurs chants dos mais
l'état irait bien si nous narrer leurs
centres sont les deux chiens entre les
caisses de prétendre
adieu je viens ici je te donne il y un
blanc-seing qui ne vous quitte jamais et
que vous a donné la reine enregistré par
le conseil du sceau privé
et oui le jure sur sa couronne
d'accorder à celui qui lui présentera la
grâce quelle qu'elle soit qui lui
demandera donnez moi ce blanc-seing et
vous aurez les titres de jeunes talbot
papier pour papier que veux tu faire de
ce blanc seing
mais en angleterre
je suis sous mandat d'exécutions depuis
la fameuse rébellion talbot des milliers
de ceux de ma race qui ont été primés
ont jamais vu le jour suivant je suis
obligé de me déguiser en mendiant pour
venir ici de temps en temps car j'aime
ce pays et je ne me sens bien qu'au
milieu de ce doux sensible et malheureux
peuple de londres hélas si rudement
malmené avec ce blanc-seing qui me
rendrait invulnérable je pourrais enfin
travailler ici à saper la détruire cet
effroyable tirs amis donc vous êtes
signol fabien dit gardez vos insultes
parlons à faire je ne puis vous donner
ce blanc seing
que dirait la reine
et puis demain je puis comme vous être
disgracié ce blanc-seing c'est ma
sauvegarde
c'est ma tête qu'est ce que cela me fait
demandez-moi autre chose je veux ce
blanc-seing juifs donne moi les paquets
de leurs talbot salomon 18 vas-tu te
décider
d'abord montre-moi ses papiers je veux
les voir après que j'aurais lu leblanc
tout est pareil son dessin normal nous
marie tudor reine d'angleterre fait son
serment sur le livre d'or de notre mère
mais tu content maintenant c'est bien
mais là vous voyez je suis comme vous
prudent mais honnête j'ai tout calculé
tout prévu je vais vous apporter dans un
instant les papiers tu n'avais pas ses
papiers doublé seulement me voler un men
ont failli y aller tout prévu accepter
ça je suis réveillé retraite agit tout
un sens bateliers j'arrive dany je suis
fils a brûlé mont blanc seing mais il
est mon ami
il n'avait rien ils sont tous pareils
le mensonge et le vol je peux pas
laisser là
atelier à rim tabac j'ai à te parler
j'ai entendu appeler mathelier c'est
vous mon avis
je
le manga juifs assassinés
à
gibert d'un enveloppe
vous trouverez les preuves de confiance
et les jeunes
la vigueur de leurs hôtes allemands
[Musique]
ça
vous l'avez
[Musique]
qui sont à vous enfin j'ai les bras
rangez vous
non
que je me venge
que tu veux dire
[Musique]
la jeune serait l'héritière ne leur
talent peau
alors qu'elle embrasse ils voulaient ses
papiers qui m'appartient je mets perles
pour aux mondiaux je te mangerais qui va
là on vient d'assassiner un homme mais
un juif qui a tué cet homme par dieu
vous moi vous aussi dire qu'il vient
cadavres à terre deux hommes à côté pas
de témoin lequel est l'assassin rien ne
prouve que ce soit l'un plutôt que
l'autre
l'assassin c'est vous ah oui au fait
c'est moi et après je rappeler les
gardes et 10 mois enlevé ça vous allez
médias jeté le corps à l'eau ne soit
plus dont un de nous deux a fait le coup
moi je suis un noble lord vous vous est
ce un manant un homme du peuple
un gentilhomme qui tue un juif peut
qu'être sous demande un homme du peuple
qui en tue un autre est pendu ou sauriez
si vous ne dénoncez je vous dénonce on
me croira plutôt que vous en tout cas
les chances se sont inégales témoin pas
de preuve
vous inquiétez pas la tamise est proche
alors mon ami bonne nuit allez à vos
affaires et bien que voulez vous quelque
argent pour votre silence en conscience
je ne vous dois rien mais voulait alors
prendre et en partant eh bien allez vous
en qu'attendez vous encore savoir ce que
vous allez faire la fois rester là si
bon vous semble à vous la belle étoile à
moi label dieu vous garde les vous ainsi
alors dieu chez moi comment je vous oui
chez moi elle est celui de nous qui rêve
tout à l'heure la société juive c'était
moi maintenant cette maison est la vôtre
ou celle de ma maîtresse ce qui revient
au même
répétez ce que vous venez de dire jeudi
la mise puisque vous êtes sourd que
cette maison est celle d'une belle fille
qui est ma maîtresse et moi je dis que
tu es un malfaiteur est un assassin que
je veux et étranglée et qu'elle
n'emporte ce diable d'homme gilbert
ciseleur du poignard sanglant que tu
tiens la main
j'en ai ma fiancée et moi je suis le
chevalier à millas pas au lait et jeanne
et ma maîtresse documents que l'orque
lembras il le favori de la reine
on va les venues me reprendre se
poignarde or cette nuit les poignards se
ressemblent je reconnais mon travail
alors dis-moi que jeune n'est pas ta
maîtresse
et que tu t'amuses de ma colère
connais-tu son écriture je serai seul
cette nuit vous pouvez venir
j'aime je sais pas vrai
c'est pas possible tu aurais déshonoré
ma fiancée emploie des mots bien
solennel pour nos quelques heures de
récréation
bon tu te rendras raison je veux bien où
est ton épée a j'oubliai les manants qui
a emporté une sont punis de mort rage
être du peuple n'avoir que c'est son
léger dans peau mais tu ne restera pas
en ville en temps tu sèches pays est à
mort de ma vie je t'attendrai la nuit je
tu assassines ray au coin d'une rue
misérable voilà vous êtes blanc mon ami
je te jure je me vengerai de toi repens
défi je te dénonçant au palais de la
reine
mais la quête chasserons comme un chien
alors mon ami rentre chez toi je suis
fâché que tu ai découvert cela et je
suis beau joueur et je te laisse la
belle le jour d'ailleurs va bientôt
paraître nous n'aurions plus assez de
temps mon attention d'ailleurs n'était
pas de pousser la mouette plus loin que
vannes en vaille la peine
mais elle a encore beaucoup à apprendre
tu profiteras au moins des leçons que je
lui ai donné à les rentrer chez elle va
snacks a frappé quatre coups contre le
vol elle couvrira c'est notre signal ou
si tu préfères m'avait confié cette clé
mais comme la femme que tu aimes et
probablement l'héritière de l'oréal beau
je crois qu'elle est perdue pour toi et
comme je te vois fou de jalousie
si tu préfères là dessus avec ça cela
nous simplifierait bien des choses à
tous deux
[Musique]
dames conduire sur l'autre rive est tu
reviendras aussitôt battu si je tenais
ce collier qui vaut 2000 marcs d'or mais
je tuerai le pape pour moins de sa
commande et monseigneur il est à tour
qui doit mourir l'homme qui la bat
pleure sur le banc devant la maison et
dans la maison une jeune fille
il faut que des temples jour tu agisse
de la tamise se referme sur et avant le
jeu les cartes de la tamise sont muettes
monseigneur allons vite entendu il faut
qu'avant les retours du batelier nous
sauvions ces deux êtres
je me charge utile lorsque j'emmène avec
moi des coups sont partis
vous ouvrez la chambre de la jeune fille
et vous emmènerez de gré ou de force au
palais de la reine dans l'état vous la
trouverez j'y serai ne lui laissait pas
le temps d'attendre à ses jours et
surtout ne les dit un symbole
n'êtes vous pas maître simon renard le
ciel ou l'enfer qui vous envoie les deux
mon ami je viens d'apprendre quelques
instants plus de choses terribles comme
interne on peut porter et ça m'est égal
de mourir si je peux être vengé
mais vous qui êtes tout puissant ne
pouvez vous m'aider
oui mangez moi de leur clan bassil je
suis celui que tu devines il sera vengé
de leurs pleins droits s'ils mais il se
peut que cela te coûte la vie ça m'est
égal
elle l'a plus d'attrait pour moi
j'accepte les conditions avis prenez-la
alors six mois où est la reine jeanne à
rennes songez que vous avez promis de me
venger sens que tu as promis de mourir
en soignant ça peut servir
prends aussi cette bourse la bourse de
ce traître
ça aussi ça peut servir la barbe de
monsieur bailly mouettes
leur avion a gagné 11 de lembras il
la fabio fabiani compte deux clans
brasil marit sait vous fabiano oui
majesté d'année et bien qu'y a t'il mon
fabiano le jour se lève et vous voilà je
vous avais prévenu que j'avais besoin de
lui de repos je ne vous reprochait rien
lui en me réveillant ce matin je n'ai
pas pu me résoudre à ne pas vous voir le
fût ce qu'un instant
et bien voilà qui est fait il ya eu ici
cette nuit leur de la femme c'est
maintenant l'heure de la reine il est
temps de vous en aller et moi je veux
que la femme fasse attendre la reine à
la porte
vous les regardez moi
tu as une jeune et charmante tête
fabiano c'est vous qui êtes bel maille
votre beauté suffirait à votre puissance
votre couronne ne lui ajoute rien pour
moi n'est ce pas tes mots d'amour dans
la journée mais qu'est ce que tu as tu
semble inquiet je ne puisse entrer chez
vous sans croiser si mon renard dans
votre anti chambre qu'il plus puissant
que vous même dans votre palais il
serait si bien sûr une de nos listes et
toi tu sais bien que sa qualité de
l'ayguade mon futur nagham pas ce mot de
marina ce philippe ii qui nous narguent
qui est beau oui oui qui est vous vous
le savez il joue aussi de la guitare
comme moi et que vous aimez déjà tu fous
fabio pouvait se refuser ce
chef-d'oeuvre d'itis mme lalonde par
l'ampli cela je vous aime que vous
faut-il de plus de nouveaux pouvoirs
pour supprimer ceux qui vous haïssent
équivalent ma mort j'en ai donné que
trop mon fabien les sapeurs j'ai
tellement peur de vous perdre
je t'aime tant a redit lanka comme ça
avec ses yeux las nous autres femmes ne
savons jamais au juste ce qui se passe
dans le kernel ça m'oblige n en croire
vos yeux et les plus beaux fabien nous
sont quelquefois les plus fourbes et
dans les tiennes y attend loyauté qu'ils
ne peuvent manquer
n'est ce pas il est en regard et sincère
mungo page je vous adore mari
écoute fabiano bon si je t'ai est plus
qu'une croix tu es jeune
il ya beaucoup de belles femmes qui te
regardent fort doucement je le sais et
puis on se lasse d'une reine comme d'une
autre surtout peut-être d'un premier
amour aussi exclusive que lumière si
jamais tu deviens amoureux d'une autre
femme je veux tu me le dise je te
pardonnerai peut-être si tu me le dis
non je m'interromps pas tu ne sais pas à
quel point je t'aime je ne sais pas moi
même
il ya des moments où je suis à ce point
jalouses
je t'aime à mieux marquerait avec une
hotte marie tu te fais mal avec des
angles
[Musique]
rassure toi je ne peux être heureux
qu'avec tous je n'aime que toi
bien sûr je suis jalouse un crié je
voudrais très visible voire savoir tout
ce que tu fais tout ce que tu dis que tu
me quittes je m'imagine que tu vas voir
les belles jeunes femmes qu'il est dans
la ville
il faudrait taxer c'est je t'aime tu
n'as pas le collier démodé de rugby que
je t'avais donné je vais donner à mon
bateliers sa femme était morte ces
enfants malades et bien prodigue mon ami
alors pourquoi n'as tu pas remis le
colis en saphir avec ce gros coeur de
diamant mon premier cadeau c'est une
fatalité marie d'année aussi attendent
atelier non non mais dans ma barque se
chasser les mouettes à l'arc buses
fermoir s'est ouvert il a glissé à la
tamise évidemment certains sur fabio si
jamais je le vois au cou d'une autre
femme joue tous les deux mois vous
trompez marraine mais je n'ai pas l'idée
de regarder une autre femme est ce que
cela ne se voit pas dans mes yeux il ya
un accent de vérité qui devrait
persuader pourtant qu'est ce que tu as
au poignet rien rien une égratignure
je me suis battu avec un juif qui venait
de me voler le blanc-seing que tu m'as
donné qu'il ait tué j'espère évidemment
oui mais en tombant il a réussi à le
brûler et je venais justement te
demander de le remplacer
c'est là l'objet de visites donc et sans
ce document je me sens l'âme n'est pas
passé mais bon si tu ne perds plus à
l'avenir tout ce que je te donne
en attendant je n'aime pas te voir mêlés
à la population regarder les filles dans
les rues j'ai peur de perdre
c'est le moment choisi tu pour me dire
des choses pareilles marie le moment de
ma vie où je t'aime peut-être le plus ce
n'est pas la reine que j'aime c'est toi
la femme la plus passionnée un plus
troublantes qui existent quand on aime à
ce point combien les mots semble
maladroit et pauvres by admin que vous
êtes jeune et beau la charmante tête que
voilà
rester dans le palais revenez dans une
heure
ce que vous appelez une heure sera pour
moi un siècle
entrez vous étiez là vous avez entendu
oui tout va je suis ravi de vous je dis
que fabien est le plus fort et le plus
redoutable des hommes et vous êtes bien
sûr qu'il va chez cette femme la nuit
vous l'avez vu le jour cinq fois dites
vous
j'ai peine à vous croire vous avez été
témoin 7
j'endosse clinton montaigu en bref tous
les leurres inquiet de la présence de
leurs plans gracile à la cour méthodes
utilisées par cette fille
mty lui même assiduité semble le prouver
ce serait vraiment une famille
d'ailleurs les faits seront comme lui
prouver tout à l'heure la jeune fille
est ici je les fais saisir dans sa
maison cette nuit quelques minutes avant
que le batelier soudoyés par leur
fabiani ne tombent entre nos mains au
moment où il s'apprêtait à assassiner
jeanne m6 leur avec ceux ci ce temps
tellement
[Musique]
si vous n'avez pas été dupe d'une
méprise tous ces faits ne sont ils pas
des crimes suffisant pour faire pencher
la tête à cet homme ou avoir été jolie
fille se mettre en jugement morton pour
un fait semblable il a été absous j'ai
fait décapiter les juges de troc mortels
tâchez de ne pas avoir à punir les juges
de fabiani ans mon père avait toujours
raison
la mort seul ne lave pas les outrages ce
qui me tue et rien à côté de ce qui me
blesse quand je pense que je ne peux que
l'étui pour le tuer certes mais il faut
que votre majesté explique que sa
vengeance par une raisons juridiques et
non par un mobile de jalousie indigne
d'une reine et que je ne saurais
défendre devant mon illustre m qui doit
vous épousez tu as raison et nous
vengeance qui souhaitent digne de moi
l'homme qui est ici peut vous la donner
at-il tout ce que je voudrais il le fera
si vous faites ce qu'il vous demandera
sacrifiera-t-il sa vie il poserait ses
conditions mais il donnera sa vie qu'est
ce qu'il veut mais savez vous ce que
vous voulez vous même se venger de
fabiani en mourant dans le de manière
cela ne me viendrait pas à l'idée
peut-être me tue le jeu le plus paisible
où c'était possible
qu'est ce qu'il fait en ce moment il est
là l'on veut dans de nombreux parchemin
qu'il avait avec lui avec un intérêt
extraordinaire
comment s'appelle-t-il gilbert et le
ciseleur de son état et la fille jeanne
se sont-ils vus depuis
non nous ignorent tout l'un de l'autre
dites ce sujet le berck il entre
monsieur le buy-in les amis leurs chants
12 qu'il se tienne là dans la chambre
voisine avec quatre hommes de mon
ordonnance présenterez c'est déjà fait
mais le style est cette fille jeanne je
crois à lui seul dans une autre pièce
qu'elle y reste
mais tout près d'entrer sur mon appel
fait entrer ce gilbert maintenant rester
à portée de la voix derrière mon lit
devant qui suis-je
devant sa majesté la reine marie
d'angleterre
mariétou d'or oui marie tudor n'avons
pas le temps de nous étonner
vous monsieur vous êtes gilbert ouvriers
ciseleur demeurer quelque part au bord
de l'eau avec une amie jeanne dont vous
êtes le fiancé et qui vous trompe avec
un homme et fabiani qui me 30 moi même
vous voulez vous mangez moi aussi mais
pour cela j'ai besoin de disposer de
votre vie à ma fantaisie
j'ai besoin que vous disiez tout ce que
je vous recommanderais de dire quoi que
ce soit j'ai besoin qu'il n'y ait plus
pour vous ni bien ni mal ni vrai ni faux
ni juste ni injuste
rien que ma vengeance et ma volonté j'ai
besoin que vous me laissiez faire et que
vous vous laissiez faire ils consentent
et vous mais madame la vengeance tu
l'auras mais je te préviens qu'il faudra
mourir c'est tes conditions voir moi ta
vie aussi cher que tu voudras je ne suis
plus décidé à mourir madame comment
majesté je réfléchis depuis mon arrivée
ici rien n'est encore prouvé dans cette
affaire j'ai vu un homme qui se vantait
d'être l'amant de jeunes qui me dit
qu'il n'a pas menti
j'ai vu une clé qui me dit qu'il ne l'a
pas volé j'ai vu une lettre qui me dit
qu'il n'a pas fait écrire de force
d'ailleurs je ne sais même plus si
c'était bien son écriture
il faisait nuit j'étais troublé j'y
voyais mal dans le brouillard et puis ma
vie appartient à jeanne je ne peux pas
la donne est comme ça je les ai pas
revus je ne suis sûr de rien
on voit bien que tu lèves tu es comme
moi tu essaies de résister toutes les
preuves et si tu la vois c'est john si
tu l'entends avoué sa faute
gratuit tout ce que je veux oui à une
condition que je vous dirais lorsque je
serai certain de sa prison
monsieur lebailly cette fille c'est tout
de suite
mettez-vous là et n'intervenait que
lorsque je vous appellerai quelle que
soit la violence de vos réactions
approche jeune fille
[Musique]